this one is from cleveland ohio
from ali hi rich and adam my name's ali
i'm from cleveland ohio and it's
certainly okay for you to put this on
the air
my question for you is what your
relationship is to
money and i know that you briefly
touched on this in the last episode but
i graduated college a little over a year
ago
and i actually decided to pursue a
career in finance because i know that it
can be
a lucrative i have student loans to pay
off in goals of my own
but b i understand that it's really
important for people to
have a solid financial plan backing them
so that they can actually reach their
goals but at one point at what point is
it too much to be saving
you know too much for retirement or
caring too much about
what you have in the banks you can do
things in the future
and you know choosing to live your life
now because
i feel like i'm very very frugal right
now with the hope
that in the next few years i can do more
of what i want to do but
it certainly takes away from the sort of
purpose i want to have in my life right
now because i'm so focused
on saving and acquiring money for the
future
thanks for tuning out i love you guys
thanks for your question you sound like
a very responsible person
totally much more responsible than i was
she would have had nothing to do with me
when i was 20.
yeah it's a great question
i think that uh it's important to be
fiscally responsible
as a young person then to to develop
healthy habits around
money um at a young age
uh and a healthy respect for what it can
and can't do
i respect that she paid her way through
college yeah it seems amazing right
anybody who does that like celebrate
that person
right there and i think it's perfectly
acceptable and laudable to pursue
a career path that will provide you with
financial stability like
i suspect if she paid for her own
college
that she might be coming from a
background in which
it wasn't as financially stable as she
would have liked and and people who
who come from that background are going
to be the people who are more likely to
pursue
a conventional career path that's going
to provide them with the financial
stability that they
lacked i'm just i'm just projecting but
it sounds like that might be the case
here
yeah 100 percent understandable that she
would want that and need that because
that
if that's the case that was lacking
beforehand yeah i think
what she's getting at and what's
important to reckon with here
is this idea well i'm going to get i'm
going to create financial stability for
myself
and i'm going to defer those things that
i really want to do
for the sake of creating that foundation
the idea behind that is
is perfectly fine like i said but the
fear is that
you never get to the purpose part right
because what happens and i've seen this
a million times
i saw it in law school with people who
were like i'm gonna go into you know
i'm gonna go work the people a lot of
people go to law school because
they want to help humans in certain ways
like in a non-profit context but then
you accumulate all this debt
right and these law firms come along and
they're dangling
figure starting salaries and and people
say well i'm just going to go do the
corporate law thing for a couple years
pay off my debt and then i'm going to go
do the thing
and what happens more often than not is
you
you acclimate to that salary and you
start to create a lifestyle
that only that salary will afford and
there's a keeping up with the joneses
thing that starts to occur
and before you know it you're leasing a
car that you can't quite afford and
you're in a mortgage
and all these things then make you stuck
in a career path and it makes it more
and more difficult to then
shift gears and pursue that passion
yeah purposeful life that you had
aspirations for as a young person
so the good news is you're super young
your whole life is ahead of you
pursue that career path in finance
create that
foundation of financial stability but i
would
strongly suggest not that you're not
doing this already but
that you live as minimally as possible
and refrain from any of those
expenses that later on can prevent you
from
being nimble with your career you know
it sounds like you're good at saving
money which is fantastic
and also to remember that it's important
to
to invest in experience right if you
keep your overhead low
you create choices for yourself and
flexibility with your career path and
you have the ability to
invest in experiences whether those are
trips or learning
things that you want to learn in your
life career other hobbies things like
that
um as long as you can do that then you
then have the freedom to make those
changes later
later on in life that's really great
advice um
the only thing i'd add to that i'd do
any of those things as a young person
me i didn't you didn't no well you were
a
dashing swimmer at stanford no but i
made a lot of mistakes i wish i could
change so my
my message to young people is always
like live lean right
you know and and and try to protect that
ability to be flexible and nimble i
think that's right and
i i think that's great advice and it
seems like she's on that path doesn't
seem like she's acquiring a whole lot
at this point right um but i would say
that this
this cr this craving for purpose is real
and fomo is real and sometimes we're so
attached
back to the consumption but so attached
to our phones and we see
people living lives of so-called purpose
or having these experiences that are
like
you know bucket list type experiences
and and and she's like
grinding it out saving money um first of
all
a lot of that is is false it's not as
great and or ideal as
it looks like so don't don't you know
you got to make sure to check yourself
i'm not saying that she is indulging in
or or subject to fomo we all are at some
level
um but the other thing i would say is
purpose doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be sensible career or
purpose
it can be both and and your purpose
doesn't have to be your sensible career
and
in in the interim i think purpose is
going to be
really important for you to be able to
get through kind of grinding weeks that
are harder to get through
and one way of doing that is
volunteering or finding some way to
connect
with something that you do care about um
so i i would say that there
there are ways to mitigate that in the
interim before you kind of make that
nimble
jump to i think that's a really
important point
and and we think of like purpose
in this binary context like you're
either in this
financially secure career or you're
living this purpose-driven
you know right it doesn't have to be
that way and it's not that way
um you can find purpose in
any in anything that you're doing in any
pursuit and
if you feel you know bereft of that in
your particular career choice
you can find purpose in just trying to
be of maximum service to
the people that you report to right or
just doing the best job that you can
absolutely you can like zen in on the
actions you're taking at work
you can you know volunteer as a literacy
coach or something like that or or help
people with finances that might need
help or
uh people in trouble with their
mortgages whatever it might be
yeah and uh but yeah uh thanks for the
question
it's a good one cool
[Music]
so
you